>> SOME CITY ARE GETTING ROCKED
BY VIOLENT CRIME, BUT ONE MAYOR
IS SAYING FEARS ARE OVERBLOWN
AND THE RIGHT WHEN I KNOWING
MEDIA, THEY'RE TO BLAME.
>> YOU KNOW, THERE'S A LOT OF
NOISE ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
OUR CITY.
YOU SEE IT IN THE HEADLINES,
OFTEN IN THE RIGHT WING MEDIA.
THEY LOVE TO TALK ABOUT SAN
FRANCISCO, DON'T THEY?
YOU SEE IT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
YOU SEE ONE VIDEO TAKE OFF AS IF
IT'S TELLING THE WHOLE TRUTH
ABOUT WHO WE ARE.
>> OH, YOU'RE NOT.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN,
JUDGE.
>> I DIDN'T INTEND TO SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
SHE'S NOT.
I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW, SHE'S
NOT, OKAY?
SHE'S THE ONE WHO SAID HOW MANY
MONTHS AGO, IT'S TIME THE REIGN
OF CRIMINALS DESTROYING OUR
CITY, IT'S TIME TO COME TO AN
END AND IT COMES TO AN END WHEN
WE TAKE THE STEPS TO BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IS SHE CRAZY?
WE HAVE BLACK LIVES MATTER, THEN
THE REIGN OF SOCIAL JUSTICE, NOW
IT'S THE MEDIA'S FAULT.
READ THE STATISTICS, THAT'S ALL
I HAVE TO SAY.
I WAS IN SAN FRANCISCO NOT THAT
LONG AGO.
I WAS AFRAID.
AND THE TENDERLOIN DISTRICT,
PEOPLE ARE DYING ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE THEY'RE DOING COCAINE --
NOT THAT COCAINE KILLS THEM, BUT
BECAUSE OF THE FENTANYL THEY'RE
PUTTING IN THE COCAINE THAT'S
COMING TO CHINA AND THE
UNDECLARED WAR COMING THROUGH
THE BORDER.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
>> GLAD WE WENT TO YOU FIRST.
YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT THAT COMMENT.
I FORGOT ABOUT THAT.
THAT WAS A GREAT POINT.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY IN
RESPONSE TO THE JUDGE'S
PASSIONATE COMMENTARY.
>> I'M MOSTLY IN AGREEMENT --
YES, IT HAPPENS.
AND I WOULD SAY ALSO THAT A LOT
OF LIBERAL LEADERSHIP IS IN
AGREEMENT.
WE TALK ABOUT WE'RE ALL HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
WE HAVE A MAYOR WHO GOT ELECTED
RUNNING ON A TOUGH ON CRIME
AGENDA WITH A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM COMPONENT TO IT WHICH IS
WHERE EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE,
CERTAINLY IN THE POST GEORGE
FLOYD MURDER ERA.
I THINK WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS A
BIT OF AN OUTLIER IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN CLEAR
FROM THE BEGINNING.
WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
FUNDING THE POLICE.
THIS RHETORIC IS NOT HELPFUL.
YOU LOOK AT LEADERSHIP, CLYBURN,
KAMALA HARRIS, ALL SAYING THIS
IS NOT HOW WE SEE THINGS.
>> WHY DID LONDON BREED TALK
ABOUT THE RIGHT WING MEDIA?
>> SHE'S GRASPING FOR STRAWS?
IS IT GASPING?
GASPING FOR AIR AND GRASPING FOR
STRAWS.
BOTH KAMALA HARRIS AND JOE BIDEN
RAN ON GETTING RID OF CASH BAIL.
THAT'S A CENTRAL PROBLEM HERE IN
NEW YORK CITY.
LET'S NOT DISMISS -- THEY
COULDN'T SAY RIOTS ARE BAD, STOP
TURNING OUR CITIES UNTIL THE
POLL NUMBERS TURNED AGAINST
THEM.
IT WENT ON FOR MONTHS UNTIL THEY
STOOD UP AND DENOUNCED THE
VIOLENCE HAPPENING IN MAJOR
CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I WANT TO POINT OUT QUICK.
GEORGE GASCON WAS THE POLICE
CHIEF IN SAN FRANCISCO BEFORE HE
TODDLED DOWN TO L.A. APPOINTED
BY GAVIN NEWSOM, THEN HE WAS
APPOINTED BY GAVIN NEWSOM, THEN
THE MAYOR TO BE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THE DANGEROUS LIBERALISM, THE
PRO CRIMINAL, ANTI-VICTIM STANCE
IS LIKE, GENERAL HERPES.
IT SPREADS.
YOU CAN'T SEE IT AND YOU CAN
CATCH IT.
IT WINDS UP IN YOUR CITY AND
THERE'S REALLY NO TREATMENT FOR
IT.
NOT IN SAN FRANCISCO HE
WASN'T --
>> SOMEONE -- SOMEONE BESIDES
GREG REFERENCED STD.
>> DO WE HAVE VALTREX FOR THIS
KIND OF LIBERALISM?
>> GO AHEAD, GREG?
>> GASCON, HE WAS HELPFUL
OFFERING TIPS TO AVOID BEING A
VICTIM OF CRIME.
HE SAID, "LOCK YOUR DOORS."
>> GOING TO WRITE THAT DOWN.
>> AVOID GETTING SHOT, DON'T
STAND IN FRONT OF AN INCOMING
BULLET.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS HELPFUL.
I SAID IT BEFORE, BUT IT BEARS
REPEATING, PROGRESSIVES DENY THE
BRUTALITY AND SUFFERING OF CRIME
BECAUSE THEY DON'T SEE IT AS A
HUMAN PROBLEM.
THEY SEE IT AS A POLITICAL ISSUE
THAT THEY MUST INDULGE TO
PLACATE THEIR BASE.
SO THEY TALKED ABOUT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM RATHER THAN LET'S
HELP THE VICTIMS, RIGHT?
THEIR BASE SEES VICTIMS AS A
RECKONING OF 400 YEARS OF
REPRESSION.
BUT THE LAST TIME I CHECKED,
ELDERLY ASIAN WOMEN DIDN'T OWN
SLAVES OR SUPPORT JIM CROW.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY'RE SO
SILENT ABOUT OTHER MINORITIES
BEING DESTROYED IN THE STREETS.
I DON'T WANT TO GET GROSS BUT I
WILL.
A DUDE JUST ATTACKED A WOMAN IN
THE SUBWAY BY -- BY SMOTHERING
HER WITH HIS HUMAN FECES ON HER
FACE.
HE BOASTED -- BOASTED THAT HE
WAS GOING TO GET OUT.
HE GOT OUT BEFORE SHE GOT HER
TREATMENT.
HE WAS OUT LAUGHING ABOUT IT.
HOW IS THAT NOT LIKE ASSAULT
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON WITH A
BACTERIA?
A CHEMICAL ATTACK.
IT'S A -- AND IT'S LIKE -- BUT
THIS IS THE SOCIETY RIGHT NOW.
A MAN CAN WALK UP TO YOUR
MOTHER, YOUR GRANDMOTHER, TAKE A
BAG OF CRAP, SHOVE IT IN HER
FACE -- HER EYES WERE BURNING,
IT WAS IN HER NOSE.
HE LAUGHED AND LOCKED OUT.
HOW CAN YOU STAND FOR THIS SH --
>> YOU KNOW WHAT FAU